just adjust your camera
a little bit
can you hear me
chairman we are now live streaming thank
you
welcome to the rochefort district
council's remote meeting of the
licensing and appeal subcommittee and
welcome to anybody watching via the live
stream
right the application
we are considering
is for granting of premises license with
the respect of the ops off license 68
little wakering road little white ring
my name is council phil shaw and i am
chairing the meeting today
my subcommittee members are counselor
eileen gladstone
and councillor james gooding
and our legal advisor council's legal
adviser is angela law
can the following members
identify themselves and also state if
they are calling any witnesses
the council's licensing officer
good morning my name is steve greener
i'm the principal licensing officer for
rocha district council i will not be
calling anyone
as part of the hearing thank you thank
you the applicant
chairman i believe that is under the
name paula paula causa yes are you here
paula you need to unmute yourself
i'm paula causer the applicant i won't
be calling anyone here
thank you
may i have all the participants in this
hearing um put their cameras on as well
please
thank you
right
uh i don't believe we have anybody from
uh the responsible authorities
attending
no
right and any interesting parties
any residents of which we who wish to
make
any representation
could you please announce yourselves
chairman if i may um
help we have a
amber w if you could introduce yourself
first please
i'm sorry amber
there's no sound coming from your
while stan is sorting out chairman can
we move to um
a participant called
damo
if you could introduce yourself please
hello we're mr and mrs chambers we live
at number 62 little wakering road
uh four doors in the same parade as the
applicant
premises which is 68.
right thank you
you could mute yourself um amber are you
there
i'm sorry uh chairman there's no sound
to come in from um
and i'm sorry i don't know your surname
um
could you leave the meeting and try
coming back in chairman if we just
adjourn for a little while to allow the
resident to we'll give uh five minutes
and to try and get the resident in if
anyone can um just